JOANNA SMITH: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
Migrating from a Monolith
to Microservices,
then stay tuned
because here's the Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What we've got
here is an overview
of what you could expect from
your own migration, brought
to you by two of
DevRel's finest.
Adam Ross and Martin Omander
walk through the advantages
and some common hiccups
of refactoring a company's
monolithic infrastructure
into something that's
lighter, more agile,
and maintainable,
thanks to microservices.
Let's pause.
What are microservices, anyway?
And does your system
qualify as a monolith?
Is that bad?
Well, I don't actually
know about your system.
But a monolith system is
fully interconnected, meaning
every piece is part
of a single whole,
where updating one feature
means rebuilding and redeploying
the entire system.
As a contrast, microservices
are independently
built, deployed,
operated, and scaled.
They connect to other services
by calling each other.
But they are not
constructed or hosted,
established-- whatever you
want to call it-- together.
In the talk, Martin
explains that a microservice
has four defining
characteristics-- an API, which
is the only way to
communicate with the service;
compute resources to
run business logic;
some sort of state-- it could
be database storage, a file
system, a memory cache,
whatever it needs.
And most importantly,
according to Martin,
a team that is
associated with it.
Someone inside the
company to turn
to if something goes wonky.
This leads to the core trade-off
that Adam and Martin discuss,
development versus operations.
Reducing technical
complexity makes it easier
to update and fix
your code but requires
more operational effort,
more deployments, harder
troubleshooting, et cetera.
So the secret sauce
for these two?
Serverless.
A serverless
approach handles most
of your operational
complexity, making
this trade-off irrelevant.
And with microservices cutting
down on technical complexity,
your company can move to
an agile, adaptable place.
To prove that, Adam and Martin
had a complete microservice
introduced within 46 seconds
of their talk beginning.
Sure, technically it was a
super simple Cloud Function.
But that is still a
complete microservice
deployed with a one-liner.
That is the agility they
are here to show off.
So if I've caught
your interest, you're
going to want to see
the talk because they
managed to use a
fictional company's
journey as an iterative
demo that creates
a relatable migration story for
anyone who thinks microservices
are their future but may have
some concerns about getting
started, because while
these two are showing off
the power of Cloud
Functions, Cloud Run, Cloud
Firestore, Cloud Tasks,
and Google Sheets,
they are also
calling out pitfalls
like data fragmentation
or component chains
scaling at different rates.
All-around advice from two
people who have your back.
And if you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]